pas bonjour et bienvenue pour cette
foire aux questions stop sciences où
nous allons aujourd'hui parler des
spinosaures idées avec un spécialiste en
la matière le docteur christophe hendrix
christophe bonjour bonjour donc
christophe nous vient de belgique et il
a passé sa thèse au portugal en 2015 et
c'est un paléontologue spécialisé dans
les théropodes il est notamment connu
pour avoir découvert torosaurus et la
dcri en 2014
oui en fait non j'ai pas vraiment
découverte en dehors j'ai décrit une
nouvelle espèce de thon rouge au tombeau
aux ruptures ni une espèce européenne et
il s'est avéré que c'était le plus en
prédateurs terrestres avoir vécu en
europe et il a aussi écrit de nombreux
articles sur d'autres dinosaures
théropodes dont les spinosaures et
surtout il tient un site internet nommé
spinosaures idée point fr point gédé qui
est entièrement consacré à cette grande
et belle famille de dinosaures appelé
les spinosaures idée on va simplifier on
peut dire spinosaures c'est très peu
pour un peu angoissant pluviers donc
cette interview va se diviser en deux
parties premièrement on va discuter avec
christophe on va parler de la famille
des spinosaures idée l'a présenté un
petit peu parlé des découvertes des de
l'histoire des spinosaures idée et puis
parler surtout de la controverse
concernant la nouvelle reconstitution du
spinosaurus égyptiens cus puisqu'elle
n'est pas sans avoir généré de
nombreuses discussions dans la
communauté paléontologique et dans la
deuxième partie et bien nous allons
poser vos questions puisque nous avons
fait un petit système de deux questions
interposés via notre page facebook donc
vous avez pu poser vos questions via la
page facebook est aujourd'hui bien je
vais les poser à christophe donc pour
commencer on va faire une petite
définition donc les spinosaures qu'est
ce que c'est et qu'est ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur de cette famille les
spinosaures dit c'est un groupe de
dinosaures carnivores des dinosaures
théropodes il faut savoir que les
théropodes sont des dinosaures
majoritairement carnivore qui ont donné
naissance aux oiseaux les oiseaux sont
des dinosaures ce sont des dinosaures
théropodes est longue les spinosaures
idée c'est un groupe de terroristes iman
me tiff qui comprend plusieurs gens
plusieurs espèces de dinosaures
carnivores qui ont vécu au crétacé pour
le moment il ya entre 150 et 100
millions d'années ça comprendre des
dinosaures carnivores qui ont la
particularité d'avoir un crâne très
proche de celui des crocodiliens dans sa
morphologie c'est-à-dire un museau très
allongée vers l'avant une marge des
dents qui sigmoïde c'est à dire qui
n'est pas droite mais qui est ont doublé
qui permet à certaines dents de pointer
vers l'avant par exemple et d'avoir
également des dents coniques qui soit
n'ont pas de denticules du tout ce qui
n'est pas vraiment cas parmi les
dinosaures carnivores soit de toutes
petites denticules c'est un résidu
l'ecdc ria sion comme ça raconte voilà
exactement ce sont des ces rations et ce
sont des dinosaures relativement grand
et il semblerait que ce soit des
dinosaures semi aquatique qui avait eu
un mode de vie piscivores qui devait se
nourrir majoritairement de poisson
quelle espèce de dinosaure retrouve dans
cette famille alors on retrouve bien
évidemment le plus célèbre d'entre eux
c'est spinosaurus haided diakhou ce qui
est un spin aux rites et qui a été
trouvé en egypte et qui semble avoir
vécu en afrique du nord durant le milieu
du crétacé il y à 100 millions d'années
on a baryonyx qui est une espèce
anglaise et portugaise qui a vécu au bar
miens c'est à dire il ya 120 millions
d'années en europe su comme hymus une à
paris une espèce apparentée à paris
annick ce qui a vécu dans le nord de
l'afrique également au niger il ya
environ 100
dix millions d'années 115 millions
d'années irrite à tort une espèce qui
n'est connu que par un crâne qui est une
espèce qui a vécu en brésil ce qui est
intéressant pour irriter tant au niveau
de l'anecdote c'est que lyrique à tort a
reçu nombre de gens hésitent à tort
parce que les paléontologues qui ont
acheté en fait le matériel directeur sur
le marché ont compris que les vendeurs
de dire it athor avaient manipulé le
fossile c'est à dire qu'il avait cassé
pour essayer de l'étendre et l'agrandir
on le les paléontologues ayant ont été
frustrés de voir ça et l'ont rappelé
rita torte du fait de leur irritation
il y à une autre espèce qui s'appelle en
gallo romains mais il semblerait que ce
soient publiés les deux gens
appartiennent à la même espèce il
semblerait que ce soit même peut-être
même le même individu lequel de quels
seraient le bourg du bas ce sera en
deuil pour moi parce que ça a été
découvert la langue et au ram a été
décrite à la première première espèce
mais mes électeurs et plus complet mais
ce sont deux dinosaures qui ne sont
connues pour le moment que par des
risques craignant angaturama c'est
uniquement un bout du museau et eric
d'atr à vrai dire le reste du crâne
et puis on a affecté venator qui est une
espèce qui a été décrit par ronan allain
qui est un paléontologue français très
connu qui elle par exemple au contraire
de dictateur n'est connu que par des
restes post crânien c'est à dire il n'y
a pas d'éléments du crâne de la tête et
qui portait également comme spinosaures
et bariani csu comme une muse qui
portait une voile dorsale voleuse
au niveau du dos qui est une forme tout
à fait particulière aux états unis sa
valda recel et juste au dessus du bassin
ça faisait pinheiro les plus longues se
trouvent manifestement à la fin du dos
et au niveau du bassin donc la famille
des spinosaures idée tient son nom de
spinosaurus égyptiens accusent mais
est-ce que c'est lui qui a été le
premier découvert quelle est l'histoire
de la découverte des spinosaures idée
évidemment paradoxalement spinosaures
n'est pas le premier spinosaures idée
avait été trouvé ce qui est intéressant
au niveau des spins à 0 nice et que le
tout premier matériel de spinosaures
idées qui ont été trouvés le furent
vraiment au tout début de l'histoire des
dinosaures de la découverte des
dinosaures le premier dinosaure avoir
été décrit ces mécanos d'or en 1824 si
je ne me trompe pas au huitième but
plein et bien quelques années après
juste je crois en moins de cinq ans
après et bien quelques dents qu'ils
viennent d'un site du crétacé en
angleterre ont été décrites par des
grands paléontologues anglais comme j'ai
des hôtels et richard hoel et ses dents
ont été en fait identifié comme
appartenant à un crocodile qui est
logique parce que les dents des
crocodiliens des spinosaures sont très
proches dans leur morphologie puisque ce
sont des animaux qui se nourrissait
majeur majoritairement de poissons et
richard wayne qui est celui qui a donné
le nom dinosaures dinosauria donc aux
dinosaures puis celui qui a décrit qui a
donné en fait un nom assez dense uc au
sort et on sait maintenant que les
normes cik aux orres appartiennent très
probablement à paris aux knicks que
cette espèce aussi anglaise parce que
des dents sont très similaires et et
viennent de des sites contemporain ou
alors c'est baryonyx qui appartient à
supposer oui mais le problème c'est que
sue cause or n'est connue en fait que
par quelques dents c'est très difficile
de les diagnostiquer mais on a mon avis
on gardera toujours le nom baryonyx
parce que c'est basé sur un squelette
relativement complet alors que suppose
on ne connaît que par des vins mais il
ya de fortes chances que si causeur les
9 et 15 heures et se clôt donc aux
parieurs que ça c'est certain
après il ya eu d'auto d'autres
découvertes qui ont été faites au
portugal parisien
c'est un paléontologue français qui a
trouvé quelques dents également quelques
matériel osseux du crâne qui qui
appartiennent aussi très probablement
une espèce de baryonique et puis on a
évidemment la découverte de spinosaures
qui a été fait dans les années 1914 par
richard mcgrath qui était l'assistant du
paléontologue allemand extrêmement
célèbre instrument et richard mcgrath a
trouvé des éléments osseux au niveau de
l'oasis marie jeanne qui est une oasis
située en egypte à l'ouest du nil
alors quelques centaines kilomètres de
là au beau milieu du désert égyptien et
qui a trouvé donc des vertèbres des
hôtes et membres postérieurs ainsi que 1
dentaire c'est à dire un élément de la
mâchoire inférieure
il a envoyé tous ces éléments à ernst
romer qui a décrit spinosaurus à easy
take us basée sur ces éléments dont des
vertèbres dorsales qui montrait la
particularité d'avoir des epide ne râle
tout à fait allonger immense on a des
epide normal de plus d'un mètre soixante
dix de long ce qui prouve que
spinosaurus savez la particularité
d'avoir une voile osseuse au niveau du
dos alors eric rohmer s'est interrogé
quant à l'utilité de cette folle de
recel il a d'abord pensé qu'il pouvait
s'agir d'une voile qui devait soutenir
des muscles peut-être même une bosse à
de grèce mais il a rejeté cette
hypothèse là il a juste pensé qu'il
s'agissait en fait d'une voile sous
tendu par de la peau et donc c'était son
hypothèse mais ils ne pouvaient ils ne
savaient pas vraiment de quoi quelle
était l'utilité de cette voile d'or san
roque spinosaurus égyptiens cul ça a été
le premier spinoza identifié comme
appartenant à une nouvelle famille
absolument et c'est là qu'ils admirent
art c'est exact donc c'est lui c'est un
sonneur qui a nommé cette nouvelle
famille de dinosaures carnivores le
spinosaurus ce qui est intéressant aussi
au niveau de spinosaures de l'histoire
de spinosaures c'est que le matériel a
malheureusement été complètement
détruits lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale en 1944 lors d'un bombardement
allié des amériques
un sur la ville de munich en octobre
1944 le muséum d'histoire naturelle a
été complètement détruit si bien que et
bien le matériel disparu a été détruit
également dans ce bombardement
ce qui est malheureux parce que nous en
tant que paléontologues on se base quand
on fait des comparaisons se base
toujours sur le matériel type c'est à
dire le matériel qui définit une espèce
une espèce est toujours définie sur un
certain nombre de matériels donc qu'on
appelle un hollow type est donc le type
de spinosaures a été complètement
détruit ça c'est une information
importante fort heureusement et un
sommaire on a fait une description très
détaillée et il l'a fait aussi également
des illustrations très très précise très
détaillé ça c'est spinosaures après dans
la découverte des spinosaures idée il
faut remonter dans les années 80 pour
avoir des découvertes majeures puisque
c'est en 1983 que une nouvelles espèces
de spinosaures ite et tvi tritz et
baryonique se voilent kerry c'est une
espèce donc anglaise qui a été retrouvé
par un anglais un collecteur de fossiles
qui servait le walker qui est connu pour
être celui qui a trouvé une immense
griffes de baryonique si en effet
baryonyx caractérise par cette très
grande crise c'est-à-dire une ma griffe
du pouce et il semblerait que les
spinosaures niçois caractérisé aussi par
cette très grande gates y est logique
puisque l'on sait que ce sont les
spinners et les dettes des animaux qui
devait se nourrir de poissons savent
leur permettait d'harponner ces poissons
donc ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que baryonyx est vraiment le dîner
or carnivore le plus complet avoir été
trouvé en angleterre et c'est un animal
tout à fait particulier puisque voilà on
a en a compris en fait à cette époque là
que les spinosaures idées comme
spinosaures avait un véritable muse ont
allongé avec des temps qui pouvait
pointer vers l'avant des dents coniques
avec des créneaux l'urc au niveau de la
surface dentaire des narines
relativement rétracter vers l'arrière et
encore une fois c'est très grandes
griffes au niveau du pouce
ça a été une découverte très important
baryonyx puis dans les dizaines d'années
après en 1997
une équipe internationale menée par le
paléontologue très célèbre paul sereno a
fait la découverte d'une nouvelle espèce
de spinosaures d'issue comme i must
nerfs n 6 qui est une espèce et l'
espèce la plus complète des spinosaures
des jusqu'ici un crâne très complet qui
a été des coups qui a été décrit très
brièvement dans la revue science et suco
minus est très proche de baryonyx si
bien que certains paléontologues estime
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agit de bach yannick
mais d'une autre espèce de barrières
suis comme emule et très complet mais on
attend encore une description exhaustive
de des éléments crânien et post crânien
de cette espèce donc voilà si comme
hymus oui j'ai oublié de mentionner donc
c'est une espèce nord africaine qui
vient du niger qui est un peu plus
récente que baryonyx par yannick c'est
du bahrénien donc on est à 120 millions
d'années
si comme les murs et obtient donc que
c'est un 115 me en année spinosaures
c'est du cénomanien on est au milieu des
critères si c'est à cent millions
d'années donc spinosaures et l'espèce la
plus grande des spinosaures idée est
également la plus récente
c'est le dernier spinosaures unique on
connaît jusqu'ici une petite question me
vient donc si on a découvert du baryonyx
en angleterre et qu'on a découvert suco
minus ans ronnie gers et au niger en
afrique à avril
du nord tout à fait on si en à ces deux
là qui entourent littéralement la france
sachant qu'on ne peut pas des terrains
du bo naja le crétacé d'assez bien
représentée en france est ce qu'il ya
une chance qu'on a absolument tout à
fait pour le moment ça n'a pas été
encore fait on n'a même pas encore
trouvé de temps qui ont été identifiés
comme appartenant à des spinosaures des
pires que les dents d'ailleurs soit très
diagnostic c'est à dire qu'elles sont
elles ont une morphologie tout à fait
particulière ce qui ne permet
généralement de les résidents ne
identifié relativement facilement
spinosaures idée mais pour le moment ça
n'a pas encore été fait en jackie et la
possibilité que ce serait tout à fait
possible mais jusqu'ici non n'y a pas
encore de d'espèces de spinosaures idée
qui a été trouvée ici alors au niveau
des découvertes
une autre découverte importante a été
faite au brésil sajid irrigateurs et en
gâteau ram alors deux spinosaures idées
qui ont été décrits séparément mais il
semblerait que ce soit des espèces sont
similaires s'il se trouve il s'agit même
du même individu
ce sont des animaux qui viennent
également de l'albien obtient du brésil
donc juste un peu avant 6 heures et puis
les dernières découvertes qui ont été
faites au niveau les spinosaures idc des
nouveaux matériels crânien et post
crânien de spinosaures dans lesquelles
mme campbell c'est à dire dans une
région du maroc située au sud est du
pays un site très connu qui apporté
beaucoup de matériel de spinosaurus dont
un museau extrêmement grand qui a été
décrit en 2005
encore une fois un matériel qui a été
achetée sur les marchés et donc qui
appartient à l'heure actuelle au musée
de milan en italie un museau qui fait
une phrase septembre soixantaine de
centimètres de long et dans mais les
paléontologues ont estimé qu'il
s'agissait d'un animal avec
une taille de plus de seize 16 17 mètres
de long mais l'heure n'est la dernière
découverte en date s'est en effet celle
faite par l'équipe une équipe
internationale menée par le
paléontologue allemand nizar ibrahim du
nouveau matériel crânien et post crânien
de spinosaures et nizar a proposé et
donc les son équipe ont proposé de
nommer un nouveau type au niveau du mât
thierry qu'ils ont trouvée au maroc pour
remplacer celui de strummer absolument
puisque celui de streamer a été détruit
en 1944 parce qu'aussi la théorie qui
est très intéressante de nizar ibrahim
son équipe c'est que tous les restes
crânien il pose très bien tout le
matériel fossilifère qui a été trouvé en
afrique du nord
à cette époque hausser nos manières ya
100 millions d'années eh bien ils disent
qu'il s'agit d'une seule et même espèce
spinosaurus egypte et au final je ne
suis pas vraiment d'accord il s'agit en
effet on voit avec un collègue allemand
qui s'appelle serge asher qui a fait
également une description de vertèbres
qui proviennent du même site que celui
qui a été fouillé par nizar ibrahim dans
quelques aime qu'on voit que
manifestement il existe deux espèces de
spinosaures it et qui on vécu en afrique
du nord il ya 100 millions d'années
l afrique du nord c'est vraiment à un
coin super riches pour les spinoza enfin
il suffit de faire un tour sur une
bourse aux minéraux et fossiles pour
s'acheter une d'or de spinosaures l'idée
alors du coup toi tu dirais plutôt qu'il
ya deux espèces donc on peut pas savoir
si ces spinosaurus ou l'autre l'autre
espèce d'ailleurs ce serait si gilles
mas à haut risque parce qu' une autre
espèce qui a été leakée par russell en
1996 et russe est pensé qu'il s'agissait
d'un nouveau groupe de théropodes il
s'est avéré que si gilles massa ou russe
est un spinosaurus des ce serait donc la
seconde espèces de spinosaures idées en
afrique du nord au sénat magna sont mis
en année donc si vous avez des dents de
spinosaurus dans votre salon en ce
moment peut-être qu'il s'agit de
sijilmassa russe s'est injustement ça
nous conduit assez naturellement vers
sète
cet article de nizar ibrahim qui est
sorti dans sayan savoir si vous êtes
intéressés par les spinosaures vous
n'avez pas pu rater cet article il a
fait énormément de bruit c'est la
fameuse nouvelle reconstitution du
spinosaures avec les alors quasiment
quadruplé au niveau de la posture 8 août
avec des meneurs avec un original petit
des toutes petites jambes une voile
dorsale nombres arrondis mais plutôt
rectangulaire premières questions par
rapport à ceux spinosaures ces
proportions
les gens sont vraiment très bizarre sur
ce spinosaures est-ce que tout est
normal dans ces proportions
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
lorsque cet article est paru
il a reçu énormément de critiques
surtout aurait dire d'amateurs plutôt
que de paléontologues beaucoup
d'amateurs sur des blogs ont décrit les
proportions dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose de tout à fait bizarre mais est
membre postérieur donc les jambes
étaient beaucoup trop court par rapport
au reste du corps les paléontologues ne
font pas trop prononcé mais je connais
quand même le pignon de certains d'entre
eux alors ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que nizar ibrahim et son équipe ont
trouvé de nouveaux matériels de
spinosaures grâce au fait qu' il y avait
déjà un et des vertèbres avec des épines
neural très longue comme celle que
stroman avait été trouvé au musée 2001
c'est christiane à dal sasso qu'ils
étaient italiens qui s'y connaît assez
bien un screen hazard qui avaient ce
matériel et qui a contacté nizar ibrahim
parce qu'il savait que lisa a fouillé au
maroc et nizar ibrahim a essayé de
retrouver le collecteur parce qu'il
s'agit mais encore malheureusement c'est
tout le problème de cette controverse à
vrai dire c'est que le matériel a été
trouvé le site lui-même a été trouvé par
un collecteur de deux fossiles
il n'y arriverait pas ici de retrouver
ce collecte et il y est arrivé
manifestement le collecteur a reconnu en
fait les les longues épines orale et les
vertèbres et ce collecteur a conduit
l'équipe de nizar sur ce site et en
effet il existait d'autres matières
qu'il y avait d'autres éléments de
des jambes des éléments crânien
également donc ces sites c'est ça aussi
la polémique ces coeurs à vrai dire on
se base donc sur l'opinion d'un
collecteur ne sait pas vraiment si les
vertèbres dorsales et les vertèbres
sacré 1,7 du bassin appartiennent
vraiment on aime individus que le reste
du matériel qui a été trouvé par
l'équipe de paléontologues de denise
arrivera ce qui amène les paléontologues
a à dire que non seulement le néo type
c'est à dire le nouveau type décrit par
blizzard ibrahim et son équipe pour
définir spinosaures n'est pas valide
parce qu'on n'est pas certain à 100%
qu'il s'agit du même animal essai du
même site mais ça pose évidemment
problème au niveau des proportions parce
que manifestement les membres
postérieurs sont vraiment très cool et
puis la seconde chose c'est que cette
reconstitution de spinosaures est
vraiment faite sur base de plusieurs
individus on en est certain
par exemple le museau vient d'un autre
site des calcaires les membres
antérieurs donc avec les bras et les
légumes des bras ça vient des sites
d'égypte la reconstitution de la voile
d'or seul et base également sur les
desseins de streamer donc des éléments
qui ont été trouvés en egypte voilà ce
qui pose problème c'est qu'on n'est pas
vraiment certain que les différents
éléments qui ont permis de reconstituer
philosophe appartiennent au même
individu et peut-être même à la même
espèce est ce qu'on dit avait dire mon
collègue allemand
serge leiber c'est son équipe et
moi-même avec eric buffetaut des
alternatives sont dit qu' il existe et
très probablement très certainement deux
espèces de spinosaures et il est
possible donc cette reconstitution de
spinosaures qui a été proposé par nizar
ben ibrahim vient de deux espèces de
spinosaures idées différentes
alors là il ya trois trois choses
importantes lactalis et qu'il ya déjà la
reconstitution du squelette complet
donc ce n'est pas un squelette complet
il ya trois ou quatre squelettes
différents en un an il a même beaucoup
plus très certainement beaucoup plus
heures d'accord maintenant
nizar ibrahim
elle a fait remarquer par exemple
lorsqu'il faisait une révision dans mes
articles
il disait que lorsqu'on fait des
reconstitutions se passe toujours sur
des éléments d'appartements à des
espèces proches loi des animaux
différents
en revanche ici on critique à vrai dire
cette reconstitution parce qu'elle est
extrême parce qu'il propose vraiment un
animal quadrupède or il faut savoir que
ce serait unique théropodes cas de peine
on en connaît aucun bon ça c'est une
première chose et puis il ya quelque
chose qui qui est un peu bizarre il le
propose quadrupède alors que les membres
antérieurs les bras les mains ne sont ne
semble absolument pas adaptée à une
posture quadrupède
et puis aussi je sais par exemple il ya
un de mes collègues qui s'appelle scott
hartsman qui est un palier aux artistes
et intelligente truc qui s'y connaît
très très bien dans les proportions qui
m'a dit qu'il y avait manifestement des
problèmes de proportion entre les
vertèbres dorsales et le bassin donc
voilà là on touche le deuxième problème
qui est que le nouveau type qui est fait
à partir de du bassin des membres
postérieurs et des vertèbres dorsales
louis qui ont été découvertes
d'après le spécimen de milan dont tu vas
parler tout à l'heure le nouveau type ne
seraient en fait lui-même pas un seul
individu
ben c'est ce qu'on dit qu'on n'est pas
certain alors je remets pas en question
la véracité de nizar ibrahim et de son
équipe il est possible en effet que les
vertèbres dorsales et les membres
postérieurs appartiennent vraiment à la
même espèce est-ce qu'il s'agit en
revanche du même individu parce que il
est possible que les membres postérieurs
appartiennent à un animal juvénile ou du
moins plus jeune que l'animal à kiel et
les vertèbres dorsales appartiendrait si
la reconstitution est basé vraiment sûr
sur douze animaux à des stades quand on
dit des stades honte au générique c'est
à dire à des stades de maturité
différents un juvénile avec un immature
ou avec un adulte ou un super nul ça
pose évidemment problème donc cette
deuxième espèce africaine parce que donc
là cette troisième problème
avec cette reconstitution c'est aussi le
fait qu'il y ait qu il existe plusieurs
espèces qu'est ce qu'on en connaît si
gilles massa aux russes
on ne connaît vraie vérité humblement
que des vertèbres cervicales et des
vertèbres quelques rares vertèbres
dorsales très peu de choses et ce sont
des pertes et qui ont été surtout
décrites de manière exhaustive par serge
leiber vous en parlais tout à l'heure et
on voit vraiment des différences entre
la morphologie des vertèbres cervicales
et déversèrent dorcel entre spinosaures
et si j'aime assez ce qu'il faut noter
d'ailleurs que je suis de celui qui dit
que vous parmi les deux espèces il y
aurait donc spinosaures et si j'ai une
masseuse or ce que dit serge leiber est
intéressant c'est qu'il dit que les i il
y a une espèce il s'appelle si gilles
massa aux riches qui a vécu au maroc il
ya 100 millions d'années fait que
l'autre espèces de spinosaures idée il
n'est pas certain qu'il s'agit de la
même que celle qui a été décrite par ce
tromeur en egypte on lui doit ses
bassesses ah non non c'est pas ça qui
disent il dit que à vrai dire il ne sait
pas s'il s'agit l'autre espèce marocaine
il n'est pas certain qu'il s'agit de
spinosaures alors moi j'ai apporté ma
contribution puisque j'ai décrit les
caries qui sont des os crânien qui sont
situés la partie postérieure du crin un
os qui s'articule avec la mâchoire
inférieure chez les dinosaures les
oiseaux et des reptiles
j'ai décrit donc six spécimens de
carnets provenant des kenkel et j'ai
remarqué qu'il existait deux morphotype
2 morphologie de carrick qui m'amène à
penser que encore une fois il existait
deux espèces de spinosaures idées en
quelqu'un et moi je pense qu'il
s'agissait donc de si gilles marsat oil
et de spinosaurus puisque je vois que à
vrai dire nous arriverait m'a trouvé
également l'oscar et parmi les les
éléments crânien qui l'a trouvée sur le
site avec avec temps plein
les membres postérieurs et je vois qu'il
existe vraiment des similitudes entre le
quart et que le décrit une et des
morphologies du cari que le déclic et le
kari qu'il a trouvé sur son site en pour
nos auditeurs qui auraient envie d'en
savoir plus un peu sur cette controverse
à propos de cette reconstitution de
spinosaures et de la possibilité qu'il
existe plusieurs espèces en afrique du
nord en plus de ton article dont je vais
mettre un lien dans la description pour
que les gens puissent aller lire en plus
de ton article
est ce qu'il ya de la littérature
scientifique publiée là dessus la wii
donc c'est l'article de mon collègue
allemand serge leiber son équipe dont le
paléontologue ronan allain paléontologue
français fait partie qui eux donc cette
équipe la veille donc rejette concile
complètement le néo type de spinosaures
et ils disent que de ce fait la houle
constitution qui a été proposé par nizar
ibra est sujette à caution mais buzz qui
critique sur tous ces la proposition
d'un néo type
ils critiquent le fait que normalement
année aux types parce qu'on doit suivre
évidemment certaines règles quand on
propose un néo type in des règles c'est
que le spécimen qui définit le meilleur
type doit provenir du même site que le
lot type normalement ou lors d'une
région géographique proche
or ici donc le néo type provient du
maroc tandis que le lait qui provient
des gigues donc ça ça pose problème
lui aussi la deuxième credixia il dit
qu'il n'est pas certain que les niveaux
des ken ken et donc de la formation
barrières soient contemporains
et puis il remet en question le fait de
l'appartenance de tous ces éléments à un
seul et même individu
et puis également une même espèce lui
dit surtout en fait qu'il est fort
probable que les éléments qui ont été
trouvés par nizar ibrahim et son équipe
et ceux qui ont été trouvés par ce
collector donc les vertèbres dorsales
qui se trouvait qui se trouve encore un
milan il est probable d'après lui que
ces éléments appartiennent à deux
individus différents
d'accord mais à merci beaucoup de nous
avoir éclairé donc sur cette nouvelle
reconstitution de spinoza on passe
maintenant à la deuxième partie de
l'interview la partie des questions
christophe es tu prêt oui
marin est mona qui nous a posé la
question suivante
les spinosaures était-il les dinosaures
carnivores les plus grands de tous les
temps
bien écoute marrant il est fort probable
que ce qui nous
sur le prédateur terrestre le plus grand
avoir vécu sur la terre ferme parce que
des estimations spinosaures ont été
données par une équipe de paléontologues
italiennes françaises ils estiment en
fait le crâne et la taille de
spinosaures sur base d'un museau qui
fait 175 cm à 1,75 m c'est à dire la
taille d'un homme ce qui est immense et
ces paléontologues sur base de son
museau estime aussi que c'était un
animal qui pouvait atteindre une
longueur de 16 à 18 mètres pour un poids
de 7 à 9 tonnes alors il n'y a aucun
dinosaures prédateurs qui semble avoir
atteint une taille de plus de 15 mètres
en revanche sont des estimations qui ont
été révisées par terriens anderson 2007
oui j'estime que ce sont des estimations
un peu un peu trop élevé et il estime
que le crâne devait faire plutôt 150 cm
pour une longueur de 12 à 14 mètres et
un poids de 12 à 20 ans mais il estime à
vrai dire que c'est une taille de 2 12 m
pour un poids de 12 tonnes qui est le
plus probable
alors si c'était le cas dans ce cas et
bien spinosaures serait aussi grand que
par exemple tyrannosaures et il y aurait
à vrai dire des prédateurs qui serait
légèrement plus grands comme
carcharodontosaures us qui provient du
même site que spinosaures qui provient
d'afrique du nord au sénat manière il ya
100 millions d'années mais également des
espèces contemporaine mais qui ont vécu
en amérique du sud
j ghana tor et mapou szohr qui
pourraient avoir des taille comprise
entre 13 et 15 m pour un poids entre 13
à 15 6 cheveux si je peux rajouter au
niveau enfin la question de la taille
c'est une question qui revient très
souvent quand il s'agit de dinosaures et
honnêtement prétendre qu'on sait c'est
quand même beaucoup prétendre parce que
quand on parle de taille de dinosaures
enfin moi je me rappelle l'exemple
l'exemple que je connais le mieux c'est
celui du brachiosaure qui aussi au
niveau des estimations du poids longueur
je sais pas mais au niveau des
estimations du poids il aussi
allègrement entre 20 tonnes et 80 tonnes
dire qu'on s'est estimé
le point d'un dinosaure sait faire déjà
beaucoup d'hypothèses mais c'est ça en
fait là on parle vraiment d'estimation
surtout pour spinosaures puisque
spinosaures et quand même connu par des
reste relativement fragmentaires mais
bon il ya quand même des paléontologues
qui ont vu qu'il existait un lien entre
la taille du crâne et le poids de
l'animal
donc on peut estimer le poids d'un
animal sur base de la taille du kram
uniquement en revanche pour spinosaures
on n'a pas un crâne complet on a
seulement museau donc c'est une
estimation de la taille du crâne qui
permet d'estimer la taille maximale et
le poids en revanche ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que par exemple on ne sait
absolument rien de la taille de la queue
des spinosaures idées et de la plupart
des dinosaures proche des spinosaures
idée donc on ne sait pas si la cuve
était très longues ou pas contre ça
évidemment ça joue sur la taille de
l'animal la taille complète de l'animal
moi par exemple je me connais au niveau
d'un os du crâne qui s'appelle le
maxillaire qui laisse de la mâchoire
supérieure qui est l'os le plus grand de
la mâchoire supérieure et du crâne en
lumière et lorsqu'on fait des
comparaisons entre le maxillaire 2
gigawatts aux ors de mapou szohr de
carcharodontosaures et de tyrannosaure
on voit très bien que le plus grand
c'est vraiment giganotosaurus le
maxillaire de l'icann a tort et quand
même légèrement plus grand que celui
tyrannosaure qu'il est tout à fait
possible que giganotosaurus lui le
dinosaure carnivore le plus grand si
spinosaures n était pas plus grand que
lui accélère mais on a son match d'hier
mais par contre c'est le problème aussi
des spinosaures dit c'est que la
morphologie du maxi avec très différente
de celle d'autres dinosaures carnivores
lapurtar carabante aux orgies ghana
tozeur papoose or tyrannosaure ce sont
des animaux qui ont un crâne
relativement robuste si on la compare
évidemment aux craintes des spinosaures
qui est très différent puisque le crâne
des spinosaures et très allongée très
étroit très très à plat tic donc si on
devait faire des estimations de taille
sur base du maxillaire on aurait des
spinosaures d'une vingtaine de mètres
long et on sait très bien que le crâne
est très allongée c'est une des
critiques d'ailleurs qu'on peut faire
sur l'étude de terry anderson dans 2007
c'est que il estime la taille de
l'animal sur base du crâne mais on sait
que les spinosaures idée avait un crâne
très allongée beaucoup plus allongée peu
les autres terrains peuvent donc voilà
c'est une clinique on peut faire d'un
qu'il est possible que les spinosaures
idée faut être beaucoup plus court que
les estimations qu'on ait pu donner aux
caisses que c'était de grands à priori
oui oui mais sont très difficiles à
comparer aux autres dinosaures déjà
parce qu'on manque de matériels et
engins de solutions très différent des
autres dinosaures absolument notre
information que je peux vous donner
c'est que des estimations ont été faites
sur le nouveau matériel qui a été trouvé
par nizar ibrahim qui donne une
estimation de taille de 15 m mais qui
dit que le matériel provient d'un
subadulte c'est à dire que c'était un
animal qui avait peut-être là encore la
possibilité de grandir
donc on s'accordent à dire que
spinosaures vraiment à pouvait atteindre
des détails absolument gigantesque ce
que j'ai pu dire dans mon article c'est
que sur base du plus grand carré que
nous avions qui fait une vingtaine de
centimètres on estime sur base de la
taille de ce carré le crâne à quelque
chose de soi ressentie mais donc sur
base de la morphologie du carré de
comparaison avec le carré les deux
baryonyx ou le carré dessus comme hymus
et la taille du crâne qui ont été
données pour ces animaux là eh bien nous
on dit dans notre article mes collègues
et moi même que il n'existait pas
véritablement de très très grands
spinosaures c'est à dire que les très
grands spinosaures les spinosaures de
plus de 15 mètres avec des crânes de
plus de 150 centimètres étaient rares et
que la plupart des spinosaures idées sur
base écart est parce qu on a une si
cette carré de spinosaures idées sur
base de la taille de ces quarts et là on
dit que les plus grands spinosaures
idées vers un crâne de plus de
220 cm mais pas plus que cela deuxième
question xavier de baie quel genre de
variables environnementales ont favorisé
le développement d'un prédateur aussi
gros ça c'est de la question précise
ça c'est très bien vu et donc c'est
intéressant je peux déjà dire que c'est
une question qui n'a pas vraiment été
abordé par des paléontologues là je ne
vais me baser que sur mes connaissances
en évolution par exemple ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les spinosaures idées
tous les spinosaures et des dérives dans
cette qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes déjà très
grand les proches parents des
spinosaures idées sont les pianistes
schizo rider ça vous dira peut-être pas
grand-chose mais ce sont des dinosaures
carnivores qui avaient déjà une taille
relativement respectable but de 6,7
mètres de long mais on voit en effet que
les spinosaures idées dans leurs
évolutions ont grandi ont augmenté de
taille baryonyx qui a été estimé à une
dizaine de mètres de long 10 mètres de
long sur base d'un squelette
relativement dans et bien on pense qu'il
s'agissait d'un animal immature donc il
est possible que la riaa knicks dans son
stade adulte était encore plus grand
pineau zoric joly était un hymen
manifestement de plus de 15 mètres
donc on voit dans leur évolution que les
spinosaures idées ont augmenté de taille
pourquoi
eh bien à mon avis on doit faire
intervenir de la co évolution c'est à
dire que à mon avis les proies
on grandit et le même de taille donc les
spinosaures idée probablement augmenter
de taille également angoissant genre de
chose un cas volution entre entraîner
des prédateurs et des proies plus la
proie ou en dit plus le prédateur
grandit pour pouvoir avoir davantage sur
la proie c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
nettement chez les dinosaures carnivores
du mans les dinosaures mais également le
fait d'être grand
procure certains avantages plus on est
grand et moi on a deux prédateurs alors
on ignore si les spinosaures idées comme
spinosaurus avait des prédateurs mais si
c'était le cas puisqu'il faut savoir que
spinosaurus a vécu en même temps que
carcharodontosaures uc qui est lui-même
également un dinosaure carnivore très
très grand il possible que ces se la
jouer quelque chose dans les révolutions
en ceci allant l'environnement des
gammes kent il me semble que c'est un
environnement deltaïques à peu près
toute l'afrique du nord à l'époque du
crétacé est resté un environnement très
deltaïques [ __ ] de mer très profonde
c'est certes donc milieu très très
riches exactement message enfin sans
provoquer une évolution vers une grande
taille ça favorise l'évolution solune en
lui le fait d'avoir de la nourriture en
abondance permet également d'atteindre
de très grande taille
troisième question maintenant de polo l
h
il semble établi aujourd'hui que les
dinosaures non aviens avaient le sang
chaud puisque les dinosaures à bien les
oiseaux long or le spinosaures semblait
avoir une voilure dorsale qu'elle aurait
pu être la fonction de cette voile
dorsale si cet animal avait le sang
chaud alors je vais d'abord définir
certains termes parce que je vais
utiliser pour répondre à cette question
on parle de meo termine lorsque la
température corporelle est stable
lorsque l'animal a la possibilité de
garder sa température corporelle
constante et l'inversé la poésie kg
termine à vertes de lalo mais à terme
c'est à dire que l'animal n'est pas
capable de garder certains perdurent
constants et puis on parle dans mon
permis lorsque l'animal est capable de
produire sa propre température
corporelle
afin de garder une température constante
c'est à dire que il produit ses
températures grâce à un métabolisme
interne linverse électrothermique où la
température de l'animal fluctue avec la
température du milieu extérieur
ce sont des distinctions qui sont
importantes là ça on a produit beaucoup
de termes à ce moment là mais c'est très
important
ce qu'on appelle généralement les
animaux à sang chaud donc comme
me faire peuvent avoir une température
stable ou relativement stable mais ils
peuvent aussi avoir une température très
fluctuante exactement les ours par
exemple quand il si berne ont une
température qui descend beaucoup
l'important ce sont des animaux qui
produisent leur propre chaleur
exactement des andes aux termes
exactement ici le terme et vous même qui
regardez cette vidéo l'extrémité de
vaudois n'est pas exactement à la
température de votre thorax et quand
vous dormez votre température baisse
donc vous n'êtes pas exactement non plus
tout à fait en deux termes
oh mais au terme on est con et en
d'autres termes ça c'est sûr donc les
mammifères sont en de termes ils
produisent leur propre température
corporelle les aussi d'ailleurs inferno
terme on pense que les dinosaures
carnivores du mans les théropodes furent
au milieu terne et en dehors terne
alors pour reparler des théropodes et
des spinosaures aider les spinosaures il
y en a pas de preuve directe de la peau
on ne sait pas s'ils étaient couverts de
protoplumes pas mais quand on voit et
les ancêtres des spinosaures idées il y
à un des insectes et elle écrit très
récemment qui s'appelle syrie minutes
qui est un tout petit mécano zorro idea
juvénile qui lui était revenue d'un
sortes de plats alors je ne vais pas
utiliser le terme pole parce que ça
pourrait faire bondir certaines
personnes mais dans sa morphologie ça
ressemble à un poil mais il s'agit bien
d'une protoplumes c'est qu'elle est
c'est à dire quelque chose qui dans
l'évolution des théropodes va conduire à
une plus les ancêtres des spinosaures
idylle manifestement avait une sorte de
duvet comme ça qui les recouvre il est
possible que donc les spinosaures idée
dérivés comme spinosaurus baryonyx en
étaient pourvus au 6 mai chez les
spinosaures il y en a vraiment aucune
information en revanche l'ancêtre si
rémy mu s'était lui-même couvert de 7 km
en filamenteux
au niveau du dos du coup et même du
crâne et de l'accueil ce qui tendrait à
suggérer qu'il produisait sa chaleur est
tâché de la conserver absolument rien
parce que ça c'est un élément qui permet
de dire que les dinosaures carnivores
comme si remy musique comme de
nombreuses autres carnivores qui était
qui avaient des protoplumes comme les
confessions attisé comme les
tyrannosaures aux idées on sait que fait
tyrannosauridés comme par exemple you
tyrannus ou dix longues que ça a été
couvert aussi de ces pigments film en
terre devait avoir une température
corporelle constante grâce à ce
revêtement pileux alors la deuxième
chose c'est par rapport à la poêle
dorsale une des explications d'avoir
deux dorsale qui était proposée c'est un
rôle de thermorégulation il ya eu
d'autres hypothèses qui ont été proposés
comme une voile qui devait soutenir en
fait une sorte de bosse de graisse ou de
muscles ça a été proposée par payer en
et puis il ya d'autres paléontologues
qui estime que c'était tout simplement
une structure qui pouvait permettre à
des animaux soit de différentes espèces
ou alors des animaux d'une de la même
espèce mais des individus différents de
se reconnaître
donc c'est un rôle de signal peut être
aussi dans des comportements sexuels
alors on ne sait pas trop où exactement
ce clip semblerait se détacher c'est que
on ne devait certainement pas s'agir
d'une bosse de graisse ou de muscle
parce que ça c'est à dire le fait que
l'animal serait beaucoup beaucoup plus
massive beaucoup plus grande qu'ils
n'auraient pas cette facilité de se
déplacer par j'en ai discuté avec le
paléontologue
cristiano des chasseurs il dit que c'est
élongation des épinards à trouve ça
devait certainement soutenir une voile
de peau plutôt que une bosse de muscles
ou une bosse de
grex repréciser la théorie de la bosse
de grèce elle se base sur une
comparaison avec les bovidés notamment
les bisons c'est exact absolument les
dromadaires et des dromadaires qui ont
des postes de graisse au dessus des
épaules qui sont soutenus par de très
très grande épine ou morale ou quand on
quand on voit une vertèbre de ces
animaux là effectivement on arrête on
pourrait avoir l'impression qu'ils
avaient genre de voile dorsale beaucoup
plus petit en tout cas que celle des
spinosaures idée mais par contre c'est
vrai que comparé à lujan aux russes qui
est d'un plus ou moins contemporain de
spinoza dessus comme on le sait depuis
commis sur i met your mother issu comme
émission vécu au même endroit la même
époque mais c'était l'argument de bélie
en fait en 1997 c'est que lorsqu'on
parle élongation des épines neural par
exemple chez dim et road on est fier des
dinosaures et chez les mammifères
actuels comme le dromadaire com
cela dit aussi c'étaient les bisons les
épines neural se termine en pointe chez
les 10 m dont bd métro dont on sait très
bien que ces deux là se tenait une voile
de port un peux pas imaginer que ça
devait se tenir une bosse de muscles de
ou de chair pour la simple et bonne
raison que ce sont des étudiants
haïtiens qui doivent faire peut-être 4 3
4 fois la la taille du corps lui même à
vrai dire il est évident que ça ne
devait pas soutenir une bosse ou de
graisse ou de musique en revanche chez
les spinosaures idées comme baryonyx
musicaux minus ou la voile
or ce zh est relativement modérée dans
sa taille
la morphologie se termine plutôt comme
quelque chose d' aplati comme ça mais
pas quelque chose en coin et donc c'est
une morphologie similaire à ce que l'on
voit chez les dromadaires et chez
les bisons en revanche spinosaurus à des
épines norac tellement grande que ça
voudrait dire que l'animal devait
soutenir une pause de greffe de muscles
gigantesque donc ça alourdirait
considérablement le poids de l'animal
donc ça semble quand même peu probable
et il ya aussi d'autres théories qui
sont un peu plus marginale au niveau de
celle du rôle qu aurait pu avoir cette
crête
mais en effet donc il y à d'autres
hypothèses qui ont été proposés tout à
fait récemment part ginza et ses
collègues en 2015 qui estime en fait que
cette voile dorsale subaquatique d'après
eux puisque spinosaures semble avoir été
un animal soumis aux côtes il y eut un
rôle dans la manoeuvrabilité de l'animal
dans l'eau c'est à dire que la manière
de se déplacer dans l'eau serait
améliorée grâce à sept vols d'air 5
comme l'aileron da dauphin d'arguin
peut-être voilà quelque chose comme ça
une deuxième hypothèse c'est que cette
voile dorcel qui serait donc en dehors
de l'eau provoquerait de l'ombre tout
autour de l'animal induit un certain
côté de l'animal ce qui pourrait attirer
les poissons vers le corps de
spinosaures et spinosaures aurait une
plus grande facilité un attrapé ses
poissons
c'est une hypothèse qui vient par
analogie avec ce qu'on retrouve chez
certains oiseaux qui étendent leurs
ailes juste au dessus de leur tête en
fait pour créer de l'ombre et attirer
les poissons pour pouvoir les péchés il
est possible que spinosaures est utilisé
sa voile de recel de la même façon et à
vrai dire peut-être que leurs deux lames
de la voile d'or seuls étaient multiples
oui c'est comme beaucoup de d'hypothèses
quand il s'agit des dinosaures bien sûr
il faut vraiment le maître dernier
plusieurs ne fait pas qu'elle s'excluent
mutuellement exactement maintenant il ya
de fortes chances que sept vols de recel
eu un rôle de reconnaissance
intraspécifique ou interspécifique il
est possible que sept vols dorsale et pu
changer de couleur peut être ce qui
permettrait d'attirer des femelles venir
mais il est possible aussi que sept vols
de recel et eu un rôle lorsque le
animale devait se mouvoir dans l'eau
très proche et également
pour chasser des poissons la théorie du
changement de couleur et enfin n'a pas
été proposé dans la littérature mais par
analogie avec ce qu'on observe chez les
espèces actuelles on sait qu'il ya des
caméléons qui ont une crête dorsale avec
une voile évidemment un caméléon ce
n'est pas super comparable1 spinosaures
mais c'est ça fait partie des rares
animaux qui ont une crête sur le dos et
donc c'est les caméléons utilisent ces
voiles dorsale pour la parade amoureuse
d'ailleurs preuve en est que les mâles
seulement sont pourvus et pas les femen
d'accord chez les espèces actuelles
d'accord ok justement est ce qu'on sait
si chez spinosaurus il y avait une
différence entre mâles et femelles n'ont
absolument pas on a vraiment aucune
information encore une fois les éléments
au ce de spinosaures sont relativement
rares on ne sait qu'on voit pour le
moment pas sur base des éléments reçus
de différence de dimorphisme sexuel donc
la différence entre mâles et femelles
c'est possible mais pour le moment on
n'a vraiment aucune information je
rebondis sur quelque chose que tu as dis
donc qui a parlé d'un article qui était
sorti en 2015
oui donc ça c'est juste pour signaler
donc un polo l&h que comme pour la
première question prétendre savoir ce
serait déjà beaucoup prétendre non et ça
fait partie de ces de ces questions qui
n'ont pas encore de réponse et qui sont
encore débattues à l'heure actuelle
absolument je m'étonnerai pas que dans
les années à venir on est encore de
nouvelles hypothèses qui sortent
notamment celle du justement de la
différence sexuelle parce que ça ça fait
typiquement plus on aura de matériel de
spinosaurus et plus on sera capable
d'essayer de voir c'est une différence
entre des mâles éventuelles et des
femelles éventuel une hypothèse qu'on
pourrait proposer ce serait que
spinosaures saurait peut-être un mâle ou
une femelle et si j'ai des masses taser
serait donc le sexe opposé c'est à dire
qu'il n'y aurait pas deux espèces mais
un dimorphisme sexuel très important
entre si gilles massa aurait spinosaures
c'est une autre hypothèse
moi ce que j'aimerais quand même dire
c'est qu'il est quand même très
difficilement difficile de proposer des
hypothèses par rapport à ces animaux
comores another
sur au niveau de la langue à sion les
épines oral pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'on n'a pas vraiment de
d'homologues actuelle on n'a pas
vraiment de d'animaux qui ressemble aux
dinosaures et peut-être juste pour
terminer sur cette question de la voile
dorsale un sujet que je connais un peu
mieux qui est le sujet de 10 métro dont
puisque 10 métro dont n'est pas un
dinosaure
non non ce n'est pas un dinosaure ses
racines apside ça veut dire qu'il est
plus proche de vous qu'il ne l'ait des
dinosaures absolument ça reptiles malien
pour employer le terme barbare consacré
donc j'ai dit métro dont il ya un
article de 1986 qui consistait en une
modélisation de la fonctionnalité de la
voile dorsale dans la thermorégulation
donc dans la régulation de la
température et ils ont trouvé que cette
voile dorsale n'était pas hyper efficace
dans la régulation de la température du
corps ou et ça ça peut on peut
éventuellement étendre ses conclusions à
spinosaures ça n'a pas été fait sur
spinosaurus n'ont en tout cas pas que je
sache
mais on pourrait étendre déjà ses
conclusions sur spinosaures et faire
l'hypothèse que la voile dorsale de
spinoza si elle était utilisée pour la
thermorégulation de toute façon n'était
pas très efficace elle n'est pas plus
efficace en tout cas que le poids de
l'animal
le poids de l'animal ça ça une très très
forte influence
c'est comme une tasse de café si vous
avez une énorme marmite de café elle va
mettre des heures à refroidir si vous
avez une tasse est sera froide en
quelques minutes au laos hqe en tout cas
nous te rejoignons effectivement ça
devait pas être pour la thermorégulation
non il à terme de régulation en dernière
point ça a été uniquement proposée dans
un livre est donc ça n'a jamais été
vraiment proposé dans un article
scientifique qui a été soumis à une
révision que l'on sait c'est juste été
proposé parce que ça avait été proposée
pour votre d'autres animaux comme
stégosaure pour ma part c'est juste une
hypothèse qui avait été jeté en l'air
mais jamais mise à l'est
ah ben c'est comme ça a été le cas pour
10 m dont par exemple question suivante
celle de charles prost un article
destiné au grand public laissait
envisager la possibilité que ces animaux
étaient des palmes et et se déplacer à
quatre pattes
quels indices avant nous sur le mode de
vie des spinosaures alors je crois des
déplacements à quatre pattes on en a
déjà parlé c'est peut-être pas la peine
de revenir dessus puisque c'était le
fameux problème de la nouvelle
reconstitution et des proportions de
l'animal mais par contre les pieds
palmés ça on n'en a pas parlé
effectivement pour le côté palm et donc
des pattes palmées comme les canards
chez les spinosaures dit sa dérive en
fait de cet article de nizar ibrahim son
équipe
donc cet article qui est paru
d'enseignants sont 2014 je crois et ça
se base en fait sur la morphologie de la
patte arrière ou le doigt la phalange du
doigt numéro un est particulièrement
allongée et c'est la phalange la plus
longue de toutes les phalanges qui
constitue le pied donc ces
paléontologues ont estimé que parce que
le doigt numéro un était quand même
particulièrement le grand il ya de
fortes chances que et bien les doigts
furent palmer parce que c'est l'heure ça
permettait à l'animal semi-aquatique
encore une fois de se déplacer plus
facilement non mais bon c'est possible
ce serait je crois qu'on a pas vraiment
de preuve formelle par rapport à ça
c'est une hypothèse qui est intéressante
qui mérite d'abord plus de preuves dans
le futur mon opinion personnelle sur les
pieds palmés
mais là c'est vraiment purement
personnel c'est que si la reconstitution
de nizar ibrahim est vrai avoir des
pieds palmés sur d'aussi petites jambes
je vois pas l'intérêt si on a les pieds
palmés qu'on se propulse avec on a des
grandes jambes par rapport donc bah oui
au déplacement à quatre pattes je veux
juste revenir très rapidement nations
puisque les membres postérieurs sont
plus courts que les membres antérieurs
par exemple le centre de gravité fait
tout à fait décalé et
et pousser vers l'avant si bien que
l'animal devait manifestement être
qu'être opel si on suit les proportions
qui ont été données par l'équipe de
nizar ibrahim mais bon voilà comme je
les dis s'est débattue et si spinosaures
était quadrupède
encore une fois je le précise c'est
l'unique tir aux bottes car open qui a
existé sur la planète
c'est quand même tout à fait particulier
et on a aussi des informations sur leur
mode de vie puisqu'on sait que le jt des
animaux semi aquatique c'est un
paléontologue français romain amiot qui
a proposé cette hypothèse sur base 10
octobre des dents je veux pas rentrer
dans les détails parce que j'y connais
pas grand chose mais ça me donne des
informations sur les analyses chimiques
ont laissé des analyses chimiques
les spinosaures idées non ce n'était pas
uniquement t rès mais vivait également
dans l'eau une partie de leur vie qu'on
a aussi des informations sur le miso de
spinosaures n'en a pas parlé mais le
musée de spinosaures montre un grand
nombre de deux capteurs sensitifs
c'est-à-dire défaut ramène neuro
vasculaire qui permettait à l'animal
donc de détecter des mouvements dans
l'eau ça c'est très intéressant et on
retrouve ce genre de capteurs sensitifs
chez les crocodiliens encore une fois
une convergence entre les crocodiliens
et les spinosaures idée le museau de
spinosaures est très similaire à celui
d'un crocodile
oui et il est percée de toute attaque
petit trou pour les nerfs fallait pour
les ramifications du nerf trijumeau coin
et c'est le nerf responsable de la
sensibilité du visage mais on sait que
chez les crocodiliens comme tu l'as dit
ses nerfs sont reliés à des capteurs de
pression qui s'appelle les capteurs de
pression en forme de dôme et que ça
c'est très spécifique des crocodiliens
pour quêter justement les micros
variations de la pression de l'eau donc
de trouver ça chez les spinosaures c'est
assez significatif d'un mode de vie
aquatique aller absolument est aussi
encore une fois d'un mode de vie
piscivores tout semble vraiment être
fait pour pour avoir cette possibilité
de d'harponner et d'attraper des
poissons dans l'eau et u10 est aussi
tout à l'heure que ben c'est baryonyx
qui allait annoncer spinosaures surtout
en fait ce sont les nazeurs idées les
plus dérivés comme spinosaurus et irrite
à tort qu'ils avaient les narines
rétracter vers l'arrière ce qui
permettait à l'animal banque de plonger
son museau dans l'eau et de ne pas de ne
pas s'étouffer
c'est à dire de laisser son museau à
l'intérieur de l'eau est à mon avis faut
voir les spinosaures il est comme des
animaux certes semi ecotic mais qu'ils
devaient pas nager à mon avis était
gigantesque des chasseurs à l'affût
voilà des chasseurs l'afflux holder de
pression sinon on joue avoir un truc de
chasseur à l'affût ziczac te ment on
sent la pro à venir par les variations
de pression et on s'y être dessus alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on peut
imaginer aussi que les laisser nous
aurait dit était et été aussi il ya mon
nocturne puisque il n'avait pas besoin
de se baser sur leur vision pour trouver
des proies
peut-être qu'ils ont vécu aussi durant
la nuit mais ça encore une fois c'est
une hypothèse qui n'a pas été démontré
jusqu'ici donc pour les spinosaures je
pense qu'on peut au niveau du mode de
vie on peut raisonnablement parler d'un
animal amphibie qui devait un peu comme
les crocodiles rester avec juste les
yeux qui dépasse 200 face les yeux et
les narines rétracter justement qui
dépasse de la surface et le bout du
museau avec toutes ces capteurs
sensitifs qui restait sous l'eau et qui
détecte l approche le proie éventuelle
donc que ce soit justement des animaux
qui traversent des rivières est aussi
bon sur les poissons mais moi ce que je
veux dire c'est que tu en fait illustre
spinosaures plus comme un crocodile
c'est à dire de totalement immergé avec
uniquement
la narine qui les yeux donc qui seraient
hébergés je vois plus baryonyx eu comme
linus et spinosaurus comme vraiment des
animaux bipèdes immergé une certaine
hauteur de leurs corps dans l'eau
plonger leur museau dans l'eau la nuit
ou le jour d'harponner des proies grâce
à leurs griffes et également de les
attraper avec leur museau il devait
d'être extrêmement rapide à mon avis
grâce à ses détecteurs de mouvements
comme les crocodiles
il faut vraiment à mon avis voir les
spinosaures biais de cette façon alors
question suivante de alban dubois et qui
va un peu revenir sur la question
précédente
je crois que les spinosaures était plus
piscivores que carnivores je me trompe
peut-être des spécimens ont ils été
retrouvé où ça il aurait vécu en afrique
du nord je crois pouvez vous le
confirmer ils se nourrissent de poissons
coraux sans nom mais certains mal an
c'est logique du concombre par exemple
que le crâne est très allongée vers
l'avant un crocodile y forme je les dis
encore une fois une marche kinoïde qui
permet à certaines dents de pointer vers
l'avant des dents coniques qui n'ont pas
de denticules ou qui ont juste
denticules tout à fait réduite les
adaptations morphologiques qui semble
vraiment aller vers un mode de vie
piscivores mais on a des preuves
directes de cette ce mode de vie
piscivores de cette alimentation
piscivores puisqu'on voit on a retrouvé
dans la partie gastrique de bari onyx
donc ce spinosaures d'angleterre on a
retrouvé des écailles d'un poisson qui
est proche de les piloter ce qui est un
mec qui ne paie rien un poisson à un âge
où harvey lyonnais ce sont des équipes
qui ont été également attaquée par des
sucs gastriques
on le voit donc on sait très bien que
elle fut relocalisée dans l'estomac
lorsque l'animal est décédé on a
retrouvé des dents également de ceux de
ce poisson là on a retrouvé également
des restes d'un mig ono juvénile
donc on sait que baryonyx ne se
nourrissait pas uniquement de poisson
mais également de bébés dinosaures
herbivores comme
non enfin on a des preuves directes qui
viennent d'amérique du sud ou dans une
vertèbre de ptérosaure c'est à dire ces
animaux ces reptiles volants et bien a
été trouvé une dents de spinosaures en
chasse et donc on sait que les
spinosaures certains spinosaures
d'amérique du sud du moins se
nourrissent-ils également de ptérosaure
on sait pas s'il était prédateurs ou
charognards mais aussi en tout cas qu'il
se nourrissait de ptérosauriens bon on a
quand même des informations
intéressantes sur l'alimentation des
spinosaures idée on sait qu'ils étaient
piscivores majoritairement pris pis yvan
manifestement les également qu'il se
nourrissait de dinosaures et de
ptérosaure l'épreuve du régime
alimentaire des spinosaures it et
viennent baryonyx et pas de spinosaures
wind viennent de paris ionix avait aussi
deux vertes hébreu de ptérosaure où on a
une dent de spinosaures anges c'est
d'accord donc tu n'as pas faux en disant
qu'il était plutôt piscivores mais les
preuves directes manque quand même pour
mais on n'a pas de preuve directe pour
spinosaures mais on sait très bien que
c'est un animal qui se nourrissait de
poisson si c'était un animal qui se
nourrissait pas de poisson pourquoi il
aurait des narines qui serait rétractée
vers l'arrière pourquoi il aurait des
dents coniques qui n'ont pas de
denticules pourquoi aurait-il des
capteurs de pression à la fin du museau
non c'est pertinemment bien c'était un
animal très certainement majoritairement
missive or qui peut-être se nourrissent
et d'autres animaux aussi en a pas un
nain peu la preuve non plus donc ça va
rejoindre la dernière question de
cyprien brise qui est en fait une
question en quatre parties donc on va
répondre à chaque partie
individuellement mais il y en a pas mal
auquel on a déjà répondu
donc première question est est-il
quadrupède ça enlève on a déjà parlé
c'est a été proposée par nizar ibrahim
mais la plupart des gens et des
paléontologues ont quand même un certain
doute et j'en fais partie
voilà trop récent pour en être sûr ce
que le dire à temps quelle race de
poissons mangent est il donc ça les
races de poissons déjà le on va dire
espèces de poissons et les sortes de
poissons on va dire ben y avait quand
même pas mal à une grande diversité de
poisson on parle de spinosaures parce
que les l'écosystème des qualités mais
relativement bien connue donc y avait
beaucoup d'espèces de poissons
différents qu'on avait des poissons si
on avait laissé là quand on avait des 19
ton avait des requins on avait d'autres
poissons active n'opte ériger un de ces
poissons un rayon au niveau des
nageoires donc une grande diversité mais
on sait pas exactement de quel poisson
spinosaurus se nourrissent m à mon avis
devaient se nourrir de tout ce qui
passait nous avions quand preuve dire on
n'a pas de preuve directe en 3d de ce
que manger spinosaurus par contre dans
l'estomac de baryonyx il ya le lipides
hôtesses oui et c'est un genre de
lipides thèse qui est un acte ignoble et
ricker quelles sont les causes de son
extinction
c'est parfait c'est la dernière question
et on va parler de l'extinction
et bien je vous dirais que je n'en sais
pas grand chose sincèrement on ne sait
pas pourquoi
les spinosaures idées ont disparu la
seule hypothèse qu'on peut proposer
c'est qu'il y avait une compétition avec
d'autres prédateurs en afrique ce sont
les abbés 10 aux rides et les à belize
au rider qui sont des animaux de plus
petite taille avec un crâne relativement
court qui auront pris le dessus sur les
spinosaures idée sur les
carcharodontosaures it et en afrique du
nord
paralysant disparu quant à peu près les
spinosaures les débats ces âmes un peu
débattu
manifestement on est dans les restes
cramé post craignait qu'on aime ou on
est certains qu'ils sachent et de
spinosaures idée c'est au milieu des
cris tassili à 100 millions d'années
spinosaurus semble avoir vraiment été le
dernier spinosaures aidé en cela par des
êtres longtemps avant la fin du crétacé
oui l anc et les spinosaures idée ne
semble pas avoir disparu lors de la
crise crétacé-tertiaire 66 me en année
même s'il y a des dents certains
paléontologues pense qu'il y a des dents
ou des restes d'os crâniens qui
appartiendrait peut-être à des
spinosaures idées en asie mais ça n'a
pas été confirmée et je vous dis à mon
avis les spinosaures aidés ont disparu
au milieu du crétacé il ya 100 millions
d'années spinosaures était le dernier
d'entre eux est la seule véritable
explication c1 compétition avec d'autres
prédateurs il peut-être en fait que les
spinosaures idée était tellement adapté
un certain environnement et si cet
environnement a disparu par exemple en
intriguant oui en afrique du nord au
cours duquel est assez bien l'esprit
d'oiseaux rider ont disparu de la même
façon oui forcément s'imagine bien qu'un
prédateur de grande taille moyenne très
adapté un type de poids qui doit être
elle-même demande taille exactement
toute façon des animaux de grande taille
sont toujours les plus sensibles eghezée
par iations de l'environnement tout à
fait et enfin le meilleur pour la fin je
pense la question ultime celle pour
laquelle vous avez attendu jusqu'à la
fin de cette vidéo
est-ce que spinosaurus égyptiens cus
peut vaincre le tyrannosaurus rex
oui alors c'est pas une question subie
l'an soit parce qu'on peut apporter des
informations intéressantes la première
chose à savoir c'est que spinosaurus et
tyrannosaure on est qu on a des endroits
très différents tyrannosaur c'est
l'amérique du nord spinosaures c'est
l'afrique du nord que les développeurs
de étaient déjà séparés par l'atlantique
exactement
au crétacé mais surtout ils ont vécu à
des époques totalement différente ils
ont certes vécu au crétacé supérieur
mais spinosaures c'est à la base du
crétacé supérieur il ya 100 millions
d'années alors que tyrannosaure c'est à
la toute fin du crétacé supérieur il y a
environ 70 à 66 millions d'années donc
le temps qui sépare le tyrannosaure du
spinosaures c'est environ 40 millions
d'avis lorsque les gens posent la
question de savoir si un spinosaures
besoin sentir l'odeur c'est comme si on
demandait si ce soir ce n'est guère la
possibilité de se battre avec nos
ancêtres 10 à 40 millions d'années ce
qu'on peut dire quand même c'est que le
crâne du spinosaurus est quand même très
fragile parce que c'est un museau très
long très étroit très bas en revanche le
crâne du tyrannosaure est tout à fait
massive tout est fait pour que le
tyrannosaure occasionne des morsures
extrêmement puissante
or à mon avis les morsures de
spinosaures ne devait pas être si si
importante que cela parce que georges
eurasien pas croit justement le
dinosaure pète la nuque sommes retirés
que c'était fait quelle honte
je doute que ce soit possible encore une
fois le crâne des spinosaures était
vraiment relativement fragile au lieu de
comparer spinosaures à thierno lô on
peut poser la question tout à fait
logiquement de savoir qui aurait pu
vaincre les spinosaures entre
spinosaures et carcharodontosaures us à
les deux ont vécu au même endroit à la
même époque il était très certainement
contemporain mais les deux étaient très
imposant à mon avis se sont jamais
battus souvent vraiment pas pourquoi le
ferai parce que spinosaures avait été
adapté à se nourrir de poissons alors
que carcharodontosaures c'était
certainement des dinosaures herbivores
étaient thumesnil peut-être pas donc il
devait pas ils devaient pas se battre
pop la nourriture et je doute qu'ils
devaient se battre pour du territoire un
peu comme se demandait qui gagnent entre
le crocodile et le lion tout ça voilà
leur champ de compétence chevauchent pas
vraiment n'avait rien à gagner
maintenant au niveau du crâne le crâne
ou deux
car 40 over était certainement
climatique massif que celui de
spinosaures on va dire que ce serait
carcharodontosaures qui gagne au jeu de
la mort cher au jeu de la morsure
je pense que s'il ya un tyrannosaure
s'attaquer à spinosaures dans l'eau il
se prendrait une raclée ça c'est sûr tu
vois vraiment pas pourquoi mais je vois
pas pourquoi je dirais que ce coup dans
l'eau en sachant très bien qu'ils
restent philosophes ont cessé voilà si
si on devait ramener les de la vie si on
devait les faire se battre pour le fun
je pense que ça dépendrait du terrain
exactement cinq ans et c'est bien ça on
c'est à dire que ce serait spinosaures
qui gagnerait dans l'eau et se serait
tyrannosaure qui gagnerait sur la terre
ferme la en tout cas si spinosaures ce
n'est pas comme un croque aussi genre si
le choc par le cou et qui l'emmène dans
l'eau tout de suite tu peux aussi ville
le noir c'est possible je fais à mesure
il peut toujours essayer nager avec ses
petits bras
voilà c'est comme les pokémon donc ça
dépend du terrain il est vraiment repas
sur la conclusion voilà ce qu'il faut
voir spinosaures comme un pokémon eau
s'il advenait se bat dans l'eau il est
plus fort exactement
tyrannosaur à la pokémon je sais pas
quoi dire être un pokémon grandes
gueules petit bras ainsi se termine
cette interview du docteur christophe
hendrix donc merci beaucoup d'y avoir
participé
merci à vous merci de m'avoir invité
merci aussi à toutes les questions qui
ont été posées
d'ailleurs si vous avez d'autres
questions n'hésitez pas à les poser dans
les commentaires et s'il y en a
certaines qui reviennent plus souvent et
qui concerne en particulier les
théropodes puisque christophe est un
spécialiste des théropodes et bien il
viendra certainement y répondre durant
une seconde interview s'il est d'accord
avec grand plaisir
voilà donc merci à tous de nous avoir
écoutés jusque là à très bientôt